[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta en esta ocasión vamos a
Zelanda en Países Bajos a una de las
mayores catástrofes de su historia El
batage nutramp una enorme inundación en
el mar del Norte que cobró la vida de
más de dos mil personas y arrasó con
200.000 hectáreas de tierra las vidas de
los últimos sobrevivientes de la
catástrofe de 1953 siguen estando
marcadas por aquella noche de invierno
durante la cual muchos diques de la
región de Zelanda no pudieron resistir
la subida de las aguas que arrasaron con
todo a su paso todo un país quedó
traumatizado tras la tragedia los
neerlandeses construyeron numerosos
diques y barreras 40 años de trabajos
titánicos conocidos Como el plan Delta
el papel de la junta de administración
del agua organismo responsable de la
lucha contra las inundaciones y del
mantenimiento de canales se reforzó
considerablemente la tragedia pero
actualmente con el calentamiento global
el cambio climático y el riesgo de tener
fenómenos naturales cada vez más
inhumanos serán suficientes las medidas
tomadas por el país Esta es la historia
agua de dónde podría venir miró a su
alrededor y vio un pequeño hoyo en el
dique
por el que corría un fino hilo de agua
cualquier niño holandés se habría
estremecido al pensar que hubiese una
fuga en el dique en un instante el niño
supo que tenía que hacer metió el dedo
en el agujero para cerrarlo el hilo de
agua se detuvo
los neerlandeses conocen muy bien el
cuento de Hans brinker pero hace 70 años
ni siquiera el coraje de este niño
habría bastado para salvar estos
polderes del agua
el primero de febrero de 1953 en la
provincia de Zelanda tuvo lugar la peor
inundación de la historia de los Países
Bajos a su paso arrasó con miles de
casas casi 2000 personas murieron
ahogadas
ya sobrevivió pero no ha olvidado ni un
segundo de aquel fatídico día de
invierno
ahí fue donde las olas golpearon con más
fuerza y fue ahí cuando el dique se
rompió porque cada vez había más y más
agua y entró tanta agua en el polder que
acabó completamente inundado vivir en un
polder detrás de un dique significa
estar permanentemente conectado al mar
uno vive con él lo tiene en cuenta
constantemente cuando uno vive aquí
siempre sabe cuando va a haber marea
alta y cuando puede hacer peligroso en
1953 la gente también lo tenía en cuenta
Simplemente no esperaba que el agua
subiera tanto antes el agua ya había
subido mucho pero nunca tanto como en
en ese entonces ya vivía en esta granja
tan solo unos metros del dique cuando se
despertó aquel día la tormenta ya había
destruido los diques durante la noche
desde la ventana del ático donde se
había refugiado con sus hermanos y
hermanas veía agua por todas partes una
gran tormenta en el mar del Norte
combinada con las altas mareas de ese
día provocaron el desastre
por la mañana mi papá nos dijo que el
agua no sufriría más porque estaba tan
alta como en 1944 cuando los alemanes
habían inundado los polders pero por la
tarde llegó la marea alta y con ella el
agua subió otros tres metros y medio en
las primeras horas de la tarde el agua
subía cada vez más el nivel del agua
subía y subía en la casa estábamos
arriba en el ático y oíamos las vacas
primero caminar luego nadar y después
todo quedó en silencio Todas se ahogaron
horas de espera y terror que quedaron
grabadas para siempre en su memoria
Aunque sus parientes cercanos
sobrevivieron ya perdió a varios
familiares en la catástrofe
Esta es mi tía con mi sobrina y su
esposo los tres murieron ahogados
de las 1800 Víctimas de las inundaciones
104 nunca fueron encontradas otras
víctimas fueron encontradas pero estaban
irreconocibles
Más allá de la tragedia personal toda la
región quedó traumatizada por la
inundación en el cementerio de esta
Venice un gran número de tumbas tiene
grabada la fecha del primero de febrero
de 1953 Mientras que otras permanecen
anónimas
aquí ya sé alguien cuyo cuerpo fue
encontrado
pero no hay nombre 70 años después ya
sigue yendo regularmente a recordarlos
estamos frente a la tumba de mi abuelo
que fue asesinado en noviembre de 1946
mi abuela solo tiene una lápida
conmemorativa porque nunca fue
encontrada
Así es que es solo su memoria
en memoria de las víctimas hay algo que
ya nunca olvida hacer ir a votar cada
cuatro años por la junta de
administración del agua 21 juntas
repartidas en los Países Bajos que se
ocupan del mantenimiento de los diques
en 1953 el país entero estaba ocupado en
la reconstrucción de la posguerra como
consecuencia el mantenimiento de los
diques había quedado en pausa durante un
tiempo sin embargo un ingeniero había
alertado del frágil estado de estos
el último informe que presentó una
semana antes de la catastrófica
inundación de 1953 indicaba que en caso
de una fuerte subida del nivel de las
aguas estas podrían subir entre 60 y 90
centímetros por encima de los diques
pero los neerlandeses aprendieron de
esta catástrofe las ideas este
visionario ingeniero acabaron siendo
implementadas en el plan Delta en vez de
protegerse simplemente ampliando o
elevando los diques la idea era cerrar
los estuarios durante 30 años se
construyeron ocho enormes barreras para
proteger Zelanda la más grande se
encuentra aquí en la desembocadura de la
escalda oriental
[Música]
cuando se prevé que el nivel del agua
superará los 3 Metros Se bajan las
decenas de compuertas de esta enorme
infraestructura
cuando se decide cerrar la barrera Vamos
al panel de control y pulsamos el botón
actuamos Unas cuatro horas antes de que
se alcance el nivel de riesgo de la
subida del agua
desde su construcción la Barrera ha sido
cerrada 28 veces datos que las
autoridades neerlandesas mantienen bajo
estrecha vigilancia con las cifras
actuales la Barrera podría mantener el
país a salvo hasta 2100
el nivel del mar actualmente sube 2,9
milímetros al año eso está ocurriendo
mientras hablamos se imaginan si hubiera
un centímetro al año incluso podría
haber escenarios en los que estuviera
más rápido
así que por supuesto tenemos que empezar
a considerar esta pregunta qué haremos
entonces
se estudian todos los escenarios Incluso
el peor que contempla el deshielo total
de los polos lo que supondría una subida
de más de 10 metros del nivel de las
aguas además de estas barreras a los
diques se les hace un mantenimiento
riguroso desde la catástrofe de 1953
la tabla el país se hunde cada vez más y
el nivel del mar sube lentamente por eso
la importancia cada vez mayor de tener
buenos diques si no tuviéramos diques el
60% de los Países Bajos estaría bajo el
agua este dique está recibiendo una
atención especial la junta de
administración del agua tiene previsto
elevarlo y ampliarlo más de Tres metros
las consecuencias de una inundación aquí
serían enormes en menos de tres horas
habría 5 metros de agua y más de 800
vidas estarían en grave peligro porque
los residentes no tendrían tiempo de
huir ya que todas las autopistas también
estarían bajo el agua
pero La amenaza que representa la subida
del nivel del mar para los Países Bajos
también está llevando a estos ingenieros
a considerar otras soluciones más
innovadoras con el actual esfuerzo de
los diques simplemente estamos teniendo
en cuenta la subida del nivel del mar en
los próximos 50 años con el tiempo
también Tendremos que estudiar la manera
como concebimos los diques por ejemplo
podremos seguir reforzando los de esta
manera o quizás deberíamos empezar a
construir Islas frente a la costa
uno de los temas que se abordan en este
museo dedicado a la catástrofe de 1953
es el futuro del país ante la subida de
las aguas aquí nos encontramos con jabp
que dirigió al museo durante muchos años
a sus casi 80 años sigue contándole su
historia a las nuevas generaciones
cuando nos despertamos el domingo por la
mañana esta granja seguía en pie sobre
una isla seca Pero había agua por todas
partes allá Y allá y por todas partes mi
abuela también sobrevivió en esa época
era tan solo una bebé cuántos años
tenías en esa época tenía nueve años
había un barco pesquero que nos llevó a
rotterdam
le da curiosidad la historia de Java
porque su abuela pasó por la misma
situación pero la niña también quiere
aprender del pasado para afrontar mejor
el futuro
tenemos que cuidar el clima porque si el
hielo empieza a derretirse en el Polo
Norte y el Polo Sur eso podría provocar
una inundación muy grande en Holanda
porque los Países Bajos son muy bajos y
eso es peligroso
eso no me da miedo ahora todo es muy
moderno y los diques son mucho más
resistentes que antes las dunas de la
playa también son mucho más fuertes Así
que no tengo miedo
sin embargo la preocupación está
llevando a cada vez más jóvenes
neerlandeses a visitar el museo como
azahala un joven activista
medioambiental
Buenos días dos generaciones diferentes
pero también dos visiones de Cómo
mantener el país fuera del agua no veo
Que aparezca ningún político con la
voluntad real de llevar al país en otra
dirección por supuesto se puede seguir
construyendo diques indefinidamente
etcétera Pero pase lo que pase creo que
en un momento dado ya no será suficiente
realmente creo que con el tiempo habrá
soluciones gente con una visión de
futuro más amplia creo que también habrá
cada vez más capacidades técnicas
tenemos que enviarles un mensaje a los
políticos queremos que las cosas cambien
tenemos que actuar y ellos son los que
toman las decisiones por mucho que nos
esforcemos individualmente tiene que
haber un cambio en la sociedad por eso
es algo a las calles a protestar
para lograr Este cambio sal participa
regularmente en protestas
medioambientales
esa noche asistió a un acto frente a la
única central nuclear de los Países
Bajos para conmemorar el aniversario del
accidente de chernóbil y sobre todo para
exigir una transición más rápida hacia
las energías renovables
protestar una y otra vez es la única
manera que tiene sal de expresar la
rabia que siente toda una generación
contra los políticos que en su opinión
no actúan lo suficiente mente rápido en
serio dejen que los neerlandeses opinen
Sí siento rabia pero también frustración
el sentimiento de no ser tomado en serio
de inmediato Y eso es algo que noto en
muchos de mi generación en cuanto al
cambio climático siempre optamos por
soluciones pequeñas y a corto plazo y
Quienes deberían pensar seriamente a
largo plazo no lo están haciendo
[Música]
Estos activistas no son los únicos a los
que les preocupa el calentamiento global
los agricultores de Zelanda también
están preocupados
hendrick yang se enfrenta a un fenómeno
preocupante con el aumento del nivel del
mar las tierras de cultivo son cada vez
más saladas
en periodos muy secos nuestros cultivos
También tienen que soportar la
salinización
de los cultivos e incluso los matan
la salinización se ve agravada por la
sequía que cada año es más fuerte en los
Países Bajos
este agricultor teme que sus tierras
dejen de ser cultivables eventualmente
de administración del agua para ver cómo
se podía transportar el agua dulce una
de las medidas tomadas fue la
construcción de estas nuevas zanjas Hace
cuatro años mediante las cuales se
transporte el agua dulce a lo largo de
toda la isla porque estamos en medio de
una isla
pero cuando se trata de Agua Dulce la
prioridad en los Países Bajos son los
diques Especialmente los más antiguos ya
que corren el riesgo de agrietarse en
caso de sequía Por eso hay que regarlos
regularmente entre las prioridades la
protección de estas construcciones prima
incluso sobre el suministro de agua
potable a los ciudadanos la pregunta
para sal es hasta dónde Llegará el país
para salvarse de las aguas si el cambio
climático continúa y el nivel del mar
sube lo que suponemos que ocurrirá De
todas formas en las próximas décadas o
en los próximos años me Temo que no
podremos seguir viviendo aquí para
siempre Don freder ick además sabemos
que las tormentas van a empeorar
no podemos luchar contra el agua para
siempre
[Música]
contemplar esta posibilidad es
desgarrador para este joven sellandés
que ama su región tal vez algún día
estas tierras tengan que ser entregadas
al mar
[Música]
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta desde Países Bajos
visitamos Zelanda donde dos generaciones
se encuentran para contemplar el futuro
de su país entre un jubilado que
sobrevivió a la catástrofe de 1953 y la
joven generación de neerlandeses que
temen convertirse en refugiados
climáticos recuerde que puede Ingresar a
nuestra página web France 24.com para
ver esta emisión y las anteriores hasta
la próxima
[Música]